this is a talk from Alice bar conquer
who is Minister of Culture here in
Sweden and she is going to give a short
remark followed by a panel discussion so
may I welcome Minister Congo please
[Applause]
when I was a child I read a book in
philosophy I got to learn that the truth
is what corresponds with reality being
out playing all day made me hungry
my mom yelled food's ready I ran to her
was served food and became satisfied
this was my experience of reality this
was how I saw the truth about the world
but I knew very little of the world if I
had known that there were children who
did not have a parent children who were
always hungry and therefore couldn't be
out playing if my friends and I have
been exposed to this view of the world
would have been turned upside down but
that never happened instead our daily
experiences created another idea of the
world in which the truth was that when
you are hungry
apparently else and you get fed today
the majority of my friends come from the
Swedish digitalized middle class we have
learned not to base our view of the
world on our own experiences but also on
other people's stories but what stories
reach us in building of view of the
world which stories with select is of
great importance and for that we need
free media and professional journalism
the house of democracy are dependent on
a solid foundation including independent
media but this part of the foundation is
being questioned also in Sweden around
the world media and journalists are
threatened by rulers and aggressive
political movements as Minister for
culture and democracy one of my most
important goals is to guarantee quality
journalism journalists need the right
preconditions to shake power and explain
complex social phenomena the hatred and
threats aimed at journalists leading to
self-censorship must be prevented and
fought these changes new media habits
globalization and digitalization and
increased hostility towards journalists
must be taken seriously and these
changes must lead US politicians to act
and create the right conditions for free
independent media in a new era we must
strengthen the financial situation of
media we must have strong policies
against threats to journalists and we
must make sure that the support of
society is there for the ones being
threatened and perhaps most importantly
we need prevention and education
regarding critical thinking when I today
call foods ready for my children they
come running to eat but they have access
to even more stories and information
than I had when I was a child their
ability to receive stories as
beyond one's own experiences is as
important as before but because of the
amount of information available today it
is even more important to be able to
evaluate information in order to make
informed decisions that's why the
importance of professional journalism
and media literacy can't be
overestimated it's all about checking
power and explaining the world free
independent media is a cornerstone of
democracy let's make sure it has the
best preconditions possible thank you
[Applause]